hi i'm kristen goodwin on this episode
of the fox news rundown
the supreme court ruling president trump
cannot block the release of his
financial records
from prosecutors in new york fox news
sunday host chris wallace weighs in
on the potential political effects of
the high court's split decision
the surge in coronavirus cases and the
discussion over whether schools
should return to an in-person session
this fall and tech companies like
facebook and twitter
are facing heat for their content
moderation policies
that while the u.s is considering
banning the wildly popular video app
tick tock over concerns
american user data could end up in the
hands of the chinese government
fox news headlines 24 7 anchor and host
of fox on tech brett larson shares his
insight on this
and the ongoing debate over regulating
social media
plus commentary by fox news contributor
kat timf
the fox news rundown is a daily news
podcast where we
take a deeper look at the stories
important to you you can subscribe
on your favorite podcast player by going
to foxnewspodcast.com
i'm greg jarrett i'm shannon bream i'm
steve doocy
and this is the fox news rundown
friday july 10 2020 i'm chris foster the
supreme court rules on president trump's
financial records and
coronavirus cases are still going up fox
news sunday host chris wallace says
this is very troubling i mean this is
this is a a
new spike in the very first wave this
isn't a second wave this is still
in the first wave of the virus i'm
jessica rosenthal
facebook ad boycotts a tick tock band a
twitter competitor
social media may be changing and big
tech is being challenged over its big
power
lawmakers have their work cut out for
them heading into this i
hope that they know what it is they
want and i hope they understand what it
is these companies are doing
and i'm kat temp i've got the final word
on the fox news rundown
[Music]
the supreme court rules in a pair of
cases that presidents president trump in
this case
do not have blanket immunity against
investigation it allows prosecutors in
new york but not house democrats yet
access to his financial records for now
both cases go back to lower courts with
prosecutors in new york allowed to
request the documents as they would with
any other citizen the courts handling
the congressional cases that previously
ruled in favor of the subpoenas
are told to consider more fully the
separation of power between the
president and congress
president trump complains about the
from another rulings i'm not satisfied
because frankly
this is a political witch hunt alexa
which nobody's ever seen before it's a
pure witch hunt it's a hoax
in any case for the president his
records remain private for the time
being
a little less than four months until the
election i'm not sure on the
on the new new york grand jury subpoena
we'll have to wait and see how quickly
all of that gets disposed of
uh certainly in terms of the
congressional subpoenas uh this isn't
going to affect the election
chris wallace is the host of fox news
sunday the principle that's been said
here
is that the president is not uh and
there was a very broad claim of immunity
by the president's lawyers uh that that
the president is not immune from any
subpoenas he's not
in effect above the law uh the question
is what what is uh
in this case of the new york grand jury
the the new york prosecutor the district
attorney cyrus fans
what does he have to show uh in terms of
uh
the the reason why the president's
records need to be made available
but uh a blanket statement of immunity
uh the court threw that out on a 7-2
ruler so it could be a very short-term
win for the president um
the accountants have said we're ready to
go we have this stuff all compiled so
it could happen uh relatively quickly uh
turning to coronavirus president trump
again is complaining that our cases are
high because of the testing now
obviously we know how many cases there
are because of the testing but the same
number of people would have been in sick
if we weren't testing anybody
and as you've said many times you can't
spend the virus
no and and the pers
the number of cases have gone up by x
percent but the number of
the number of tests but the number of
cases have gone up by
almost 2x almost double the the rate so
that's an indication that the virus is
fretting
not just that that you know we're
testing more people so we're finding
more people with the virus
uh the positivity rate is going up and
hospitalizations
while well down from the peak uh back in
march and april
are are rising as well and you're seeing
in in
a number of these states arizona and
texas and florida
uh that icu beds uh are almost at
capacity so
this is very troubling i mean this is
this is a a
new spike in the very first wave this
isn't a second wave this is still
in the first wave of the virus uh and
you know you just look at the
uh at the graphs and there was this big
curve you know we were talking about
bending the curve and we bent it down
in into by the end of april and now in
may
and june it really has begun to go up
and is higher than it's ever been i
think we had 60
000 new cases yesterday that's
astonishing
yeah and what's disheartening to me is
that at least nationally
has all this time been wasted has all
this economic pain and whatever psychic
pain
just been for nothing in the last three
months well
i mean in certain places uh it seems to
have benefited
uh know you look at new york you look at
most of
the northeast which would have had the
brunt of it and
did the the most stringent uh
mitigation processes lockdowns uh
closing cities and states up uh they're
they're doing pretty well i mean new
york and and the amazing story i know
it's small but rhode island
in terms of the uh beating the virus
there
but uh you know it's just the places
that were the slowest to
to close and the earliest to reopen and
that's basically the south and the south
and the southwest
um they didn't go through all of that
pain then they're going through all of
it now
uh this mask war which for many people
has turned into politics i hear a lot of
people saying you know they don't work
it's just the government trying to
control you i wonder if the the federal
government messed up
in the beginning remember in the
beginning you don't need a mask don't
bother
and now of course they're changing
course well
you know it's not just a question of the
law and and
you you could have passed a law i mean
we have laws in this country that you
have to wear a seat belt you could
certainly argue that's a
uh an infringement on on personal
liberty uh
but but the states or federal government
have decided that that you know it is in
the interest of safety it's in the
interest of protecting you
it's in the interest of protecting
somebody else's car you might hit
that we should all wear safety belts and
you get a fine if you don't wear a
safety belt
you know whether we should have done
that in masks i don't know that we
necessarily would have had the time
but it certainly seems to me that that
the message
from the central government from the
federal government and from states
could have been a lot stronger in other
words maybe it wouldn't have been the
law but
you know there should have been a sort
of moral shame uh to not wearing a mask
i i just have never understood it
i i understand the argument about i have
personal uh
freedom to choose not to wear math i
don't understand why anybody
would choose not to wear a mask it it
just as a matter of
of caring for yourself and more
importantly caring for the people around
you
i mean i don't get i don't know what the
counter argument is
uh i get whether it's your choice or not
i don't understand why you would choose
not to wear a mask
well i guess just the discomfort of it
at least for me and
something else we've talked about in the
past is that you can't decouple
the health concerns from the economic
concerns if i have to wear a mask
when i do this or that i'm not going to
do it just because i find the mask
uncomfortable
well but but i mean if if
the mask meant that you would thereby be
able to go back to work and the company
uh would be able to to get back in
business
i don't know i mean is it is it
uncomfortable it's not great
but i don't you know it's not torture
either
it's not torture um the president wants
schools open
joe biden says he wants schools open
it's important economically with parents
having to work and
maybe can't afford child care and some
kids that's the best meal they get
and there's the social development of it
but it's a really tough aspect of all
this
well it is and and what concerns me is
you know it may well be that we can open
schools and i understand this
uh you know i don't have young kids uh
thank god anymore i've been through that
period in my life
but uh you know i i do have friends
who've got young kids and it's
it's brutal because they've got to take
they're trying to do their job by
teleworking
at the same time they're trying to take
care of their kid and they're trying to
get their
kid to look at the computer and and and
do virtual learning and i gather from my
friends even my kids
with my grandkids that uh that's that's
hard to get them to pay attention and
that the
that the virtual learning is not the the
the most interesting or educational
experience for these
these kids on the other hand as i you
know as we've said you can't spin the
virus
and uh you know for instance the cdc
came out with some guidelines which
struck me is pretty good i really do
think we need to get kids back in school
but can we get them all back five days a
week classrooms 30
35 kids in a class that's that's a real
question and the cdc
said you know they need to be six feet
apart they need to wear masks
you you know if you have to split up the
school day and they don't go for all
eight hours they go for four hours and
uh each each client one goes in the
morning and one goes in the afternoon
uh and now the the they're saying well
no the cdc is going to come out with new
guidelines if if that's a health
decision
i'm fine with it if it's a political
decision i got a problem with that
uh the democratic convention was
supposed to be next week believe it or
not
and now it's not going to be much of one
uh the republicans might not get their
wish for anything like a normal
convention either
no i mean you know right now uh are you
going to put 4 000 people in an arena in
jacksonville
florida when it's spiking and they've
got all-time highs every day both in
cases and hospitalizations
we have no idea how this this political
year is going to play out both in terms
of the logistics of it
conventions debates uh campaigning
uh voting uh and we have no idea how
it's going to play out in terms of how
all of those and many other factors
will affect how people choose to vote
not only for president
but for a number of uh down ballot races
as well
it's not those conventions are going to
convince anybody to vote for or against
president trump or joe biden it's just
something that we've done something
we've also done is college football the
ivy league
is now saying no fall sports at all
punting everything until at least
january
other schools have called off workouts
are they going to have college football
in the south boy
that'd be brutal huh i mean alabama lsu
things like that i mean one of the joys
is watching sec football on saturday
afternoons
uh you know i would i would hate to lose
it but
we've learned to live without a bunch of
things and that may be something else
that we have to sacrifice i i just hope
to make the right decision
and and you know the right long-term
decision not the right short-term
decision
chris wallace host of fox news sunday
thank you very much chris talk to you
next week
thank you chris
this is kat temp with your fox news
commentary coming up
social media and tech companies are
going through it right now
twitter's latest actions flagging the
president's tweets
have given a boost to a competitor
secretary of state mike pompeo told fox
news host laura ingraham
they're talking about banning tick-tock
we're taking this very seriously
we're certainly looking at it we've
worked on this very issue for a long
time
would you recommend that people download
that up on their phones
tonight tomorrow anytime currently
only if you want your private
information in the hands of the chinese
communist party
major companies are boycotting facebook
after some employees said they're
disappointed in how the companies
handled
certain speech especially president
trump's during this
sensitive time of protests facebook ceo
mark zuckerberg had previously explained
his philosophy
to fox news host dana perino i don't
think that we want private companies
censoring politicians in the news
i generally believe that as a principal
people should decide what is credible
and what they want to believe
and who they want to vote for um and
i i don't think that that should be
something that we want tech companies or
any kind of other company doing
a debate has been underway for a while
now about the protection
social media companies get under
something called section 230
that is part of the telecommunications
act and it shields internet companies
from liability from
a third party's content but after
twitter flagged president trump's tweets
starting in may the president said
perhaps this section 230 should be
limited
and he signed an executive order the
justice department under attorney
general bill barr
has proposed changes to how this
liability protection is applied
barr told fox business anchor maria
bartoromo last month
section 230 allows a social media
company to act as like a bulletin board
for everyone
while also allowing platforms to take
down obscene or offensive material
and so what we said was in the law
section 230
if you take that down that doesn't make
you a publisher
if you take down objectionable material
like that unfortunately they started
taking down viewpoints
and started really being selective and
and based on whether they agreed with
the viewpoint or not taking it down and
that should make them a publisher
it's not just the social media companies
that are being scrutinized tech
companies generally are being called out
for anti-trust concerns and allegations
later this month the ceos of apple
google and amazon
and others will testify before the house
judiciary committee
this is not the first time that big tech
has been
you know drawn to dc to talk about
antitrust we saw it with microsoft back
in the late 90s
brett larson is a fox news headlines 24
7 anchor and host of fox on tech
interesting when we saw it with
microsoft back in the late 90s they were
talking about just how
microsoft integrated everything into
windows you know so you couldn't if you
were a competitor
you know if you were like netscape a
competitive web browser it was harder
for you to gain access to the desktop
so here we are again and
it now it seems a little bit different
in terms of the companies involved the
number of companies involved a lot of
people point to
that antitrust investigation in the late
90s as where microsoft sort of tripped
and missed where google came in and took
over
in search and took over in providing
documents and spreadsheets and all this
stuff for free
online so you know it kind of took the
power away from microsoft office and
microsoft office was in its day like the
gold standard
of everything and now
you have to wonder who is waiting in the
wings while these giant companies are
going to have
you know the federal government going
through everything that they're doing
every move that they make
well and my question really is when we
talk about it now right
and you have you have the ceos of like
you know apple
and amazon and google coming coming out
to testify
i imagine if you're pressing apple on an
antitrust
allegation it's going to be a very
different allegation than one against
amazon and especially i mean look at
google in the ad space
i mean you're talking you're just
referencing google being free
you know giving free google docs but at
the ad space is different where do we
suspect lawmakers will go as they push
each of these different companies
and this is always the problem lawmakers
don't understand this technology at all
i mean we saw it in the hearings last
year when mark zuckerberg was on capitol
hill
you literally had a senator asking him
how facebook makes money and that's
comical to me because how do you not
know that
if you are sitting down with the ceo of
a company and you don't know how his
company makes money
something's wrong here this is
this is going to be unique because the
we have these massive players in
technology but they've each kind of
carved out their own
space google provides web search and
free email and well it's not free i mean
it's free to the you're not paying money
for it but
they're making money you're not really
the customer you're the product yeah
amazon is the dominant player
in delivery of anything you want from
books to whatever you need in the
bedroom to now they do groceries i mean
and then you have apple and apple's
always an interesting twist
on the anti-trust front
because apple controls the entire
process
they make the computers they make the
software that runs on the computers they
own the stores where the computers are
sold
they're very controlling about who else
can sell their products
but it's a hard argument to say that
apple is
a monopoly because and and i think this
is kind of what they always say is
well you have other options you can you
can buy an android smartphone
you can buy a windows desktop so they're
right that's kind of how they they skirt
around this they don't have the large s
to say you know they're not 51
of the market in in any aspect though
they have sold billions of devices
so it lawmakers have their work cut out
for them heading into this
i hope that they know what it is
they want and i hope they understand
what it is these companies are doing
did you hear some of the republicans say
that the ceo of parlor has now been
invited to come to this hearing
it's apparently in a letter that asks
him to weigh in on the state of
competition and social media
and that's going to be an interesting
thing to hear you know when it comes to
social media you really have
you really only have one player you have
facebook everybody's on it they have
over 2 billion users worldwide
there is no alternative to facebook and
what facebook offers facebook
is you know they're dealing with the
advertising crisis
if you want to call it that but they
still have
the the shooting fish in a barrel kind
of
way of advertising you can so hyper
target your advertisements on facebook
that it becomes
really it's money well spent and and
that's become a challenge to traditional
media players tv and radio
they don't they may have the reach they
may have
you may have a million people watching a
prime time television show
but the advertisements that you're going
to see on that prime time television
show are pretty
broad stroke ads bringing another player
to the table i think is good
i i just wish that there was an
alternative to
facebook i think what facebook is is
decent i like the
you can stay connected with your friends
you can share photos you can share
what's going on with your life i don't
like
what it has become in terms of
what it allows people to do that you can
amplify hate
and you can spread misinformation i
think that's really quite bad and i
think facebook has kind of failed at
addressing that
the the president got pretty you know
upset i think is the right word when
twitter flagged
or or sort of hid some of his tweets one
of them was the you know when the
looting starts the shooting starts
another set an autonomous zone in dc
would be met with
serious force um what do we know about
why twitter suddenly started to
i guess flag these tweets and and what
it what it sort of comes down to in
terms of their policy
twitter i think i you know i don't know
who they were about whose pressure they
were bowing to
but i think they were just sort of
saying
okay we do this to everybody else if if
i if i brought larson tweeted out
something
when the looting starts the shooting
starts that might be flagged as
as uh inciting violence and if other
people did that
it would also be flagged as inciting
violence so i think what twitter did is
they just sort of separated
the person from the message and said
well the message
is inciting violence and
okay yeah it came from the president too
bad we're going to put a veil over this
tweet and if you want to read it you've
got to click through
and and i know that yeah he got very
upset and passed uh
an executive order about it yeah i want
to talk about that because this
executive order
um you know i imagine if you know the
attorney general barr
um you know and this executive order
gets taken any further
i'm not really sure how much further
could could be taken i think
congressional
congress would need to be involved but
um but it does look at limiting or
curbing section 230 right and yes and i
want to get into that for just briefly
for a second section 230 has been called
the 26 words that created the internet
um what what essentially does it do for
companies briefly
you know it basically says if you're a
website
and you have say uh a forum where people
can go and post
reviews or opinions or you know post
your comments like you do on facebook
and twitter
facebook and twitter or the site the
operator of the site is not responsible
for
the content um because it's not theirs
it's
it's saying third parties yeah it's you
come in
if you go on yelp if you jessica you go
on yelp you write a review about a
restaurant that's your opinion that's
not yelp's opinion
that's kind of in a nutshell what what
section 230 allows for
if it was undone it would
it would certainly be interesting to see
how
you know everybody from amazon to
facebook to yelp
handle the fact that their business
model is built around
people creating content that they don't
want to be
legally liable for and that's what they
even exist as we know them now
i don't think that they would
i think that they may exist in a in a
way
where you would you know there would
definitely be more
steps that you would have to take to
become a member if you were
is that where the pay for model would
rid the subscribe and pay for model
would probably come into play more
absolutely and you know the thing we saw
from the very
very early beginnings of the internet
back in the late 90s
is the internet just to kind of get it
out the door
everything needed to be free it needed
to be ad supported and it needed to be
free
and we all really liked it and we all
loved aol we all loved paying
nine dollars a month or whatever it was
but we really liked that first month
when it was free um
and and that you know that would you'd
kind of have to change that
if the government suddenly said to yelp
okay if somebody posts a negative review
and the company
that is being reviewed wants to sue
they're going to sue yelp they're not
going to sue the person
we would have we would have a change you
know as we're talking about
government involvement in in social
media
uh i don't know if there's any more
stark an example of government
involvement than
the secretary of state talking about
maybe banning tick tock
um that is a relative yeah it's a
relatively new social media company but
i remember zuckerberg a couple years ago
saying guys
this is owned by the chinese it's not
it's not a free speech platform the hong
kong protests are not going to be
on uh on you're not going to see any
evidence of that and i'm just wondering
you know i i see australia's talking
about banning it
this would be yeah and this would be
huge if we did if we took this
kind of measure right a national
security measure to ban
a social media platform it would it
would be a huge step
and it it would be interesting but yes
tick tock
is you know it is owned by a chinese
company and
as the secretary of state has rightly
pointed out many times
if you're a chinese company you are run
by the chinese government and the
chinese government is communist
and you know we had an issue i forget
the name of the app that it was a face
app that you could you could make you
look old it could make you look like
your sister it could make you look like
a
younger version of you it was also owned
by the chinese and people are using it
and it turned out they were using it to
spy on us so it's
it is not out of the realm of
possibilities that
an app from china on our smartphone is
probably not a good idea
brett larson thank you so much for your
time jessica rosenthal always a pleasure
from the fox news podcasts network
subscribe and listen to the trey gowdy
podcast former federal prosecutor and
four-term u.s congressman from south
carolina brings you a one-of-a-kind
podcast
subscribe and listen now by going to
foxnewspodcasts.com
subscribe to this podcast at
and now some good news with tanya j
powers
a puerto rican family is back home again
after an airline
came to the rescue the santiago
rodriguez family was traveling with
spirit airlines from san juan to
philadelphia on june 30th
when their four-year-old daughter had a
medical emergency on the flight
as a result the flight was forced to
divert the turks and caicos
so she could get medical help she
recovered but the family's travel issues
were not over
you see the family did not have their
passports because they aren't required
when flying between puerto rico which is
a u.s territory
and the mainland that meant that they
didn't have the proper documentation
when it came time to leave turks and
caicos
it's not the only problem they ran into
either commercial flights in turks and
caicos haven't reopened to travelers yet
so spirit came to the rescue finding
them a place to stay
the girl's mother says their luggage was
still on that flight to philadelphia
which meant they had none of their
clothes with them which spirit
also helped with she says she's thankful
the airline even got permission to send
an empty plane
to pick the family up and fly them back
to puerto rico
spirits communication manager said in a
news release the airline was
quote very happy to have been able to
help the santiago rodriguez family
return home
and offer them a sense of peace after a
moment of anguish
tanya j powers fox news
it's time for your fox news commentary
what's on your mind i may not have
attended harvard but even
i know that spending fifty thousand
dollars for a year
of online classes is probably not the
smartest thing to do
and yet that seems to be exactly what
the best and brightest cream of the crop
students at that very
school will be doing in the fall in case
you haven't heard harvard university has
announced that it's going to be doing
things differently next semester because
of the coronavirus pandemic
although 40 of the student body
including all first-year students will
be living on campus quote
all course instruction undergraduate and
graduate for the
20 20 21 academic year will be delivered
online
it's a huge change for sure but there's
one thing that will remain the same
the tuition cost will stay the usual 49
653 for anyone living off campus and the
full cost will remain
72 356 dollars for those living there
even though they'll be learning online
in other words harvard's offering a
completely different product from what
it's offered in the past
a model of education by the way that
they have next to no experience in
facilitating
and still charging the same price this
is a crazy offer
and what's even crazier is that some
people are actually going to go for it
now i don't call it crazy just because i
think that
anything costing 50 grand should at the
very least be something that gets you
off your couch
i mean i do think that yes but i also
believe that the price tag to attend
these prestigious
ivy league institutions was already
stupidly high
even under the operating procedures of
the before times when that classroom
experience
was included by the way this view isn't
just some
kind of abstract talking point for me
either rather it's the path that i
myself chose when weighing my own
options for
my own life i was accepted into a
columbia university graduate program
when i was 21 years old
just weeks before i was supposed to move
across the country though i decided that
whatever i learned there could never be
worth saddling myself
with debt to afford its price tag
although many people called me crazy at
the time this was absolutely the right
move
and i still consider it to be one of the
best decisions that i've ever made in my
life
the small amount of debt that i took on
for my undergraduate degree has already
paid
off and my career is going far better
than i could have ever even imagined to
be going right now
to be clear i understand that things
have changed because of this pandemic
i understand that we can't just snap our
fingers and do things the way we used to
be able to do them
when it comes to the way we view higher
education in this country though
i think that might be more of an
opportunity than a burden
we've needed to reevaluate the way our
culture treats higher education for
quite some time now
and this situation could be just what we
need to kick that discussion into high
gear
even if you disagree and you're one of
those people who believe that there's
another thing that makes the high price
of harvard worth it
then it really truly has offered the
best education money can buy
then you'd still have to acknowledge
that this may not be the case under
current conditions
we already understand that there are
many different kinds of education
and that attending some fancy
undergraduate or graduate school is just
one of them
for some people especially those who
don't have to worry about the money
it's an excellent option sure but it's
far from the only option or even the
best option for every single person
and there really hasn't been a better
time than now to embrace
just how true that is i'm cat tip
you've been listening to the fox news
rundown stay up to date by subscribing
to this podcast at foxnewspodcasts.com
and for up to the minute news
go to foxnews.com
[Music]
love fox news click the subscribe button
to get more of the news and opinion
you trust and click the fox news rundown
playlist for the latest episodes